greetings world we're here today to
give you a special presentation on the
use of quantum computers to
design better nuclear reactors
uh one of the key problems in nuclear
reactor design is the
configuration of the fuel assemblies uh
multiple field type field assembly types
particularly used in typical reactor
design
uh here in this very simplified site we
have one high enrichment one low
ingredient assembly
we use our reactor design and this
gives us a very large search space in
the quarter core rotational periodicity
geometry
and we cannot simply evaluate all these
possibilities
this necessitates need for optimization
techniques
including quantum algorithms
so typically we are looking at a
multi-objective
function that we seek to minimize for
our reactor design we want to
first maximize how long a reactor can
stay critical
and while secondly minimizing the power
peaking
a safety criteria you want to beat so so
it's having this multi-objective
function
with competing needs that we still seek
to minimize
we considered a few non-icing-based
optimization methods
including simulated annealing which
heats and cools
a solution genetic algorithms and
quantum-inspired genetic algorithms
which take a chromosome view of evolving
solutions into an optimum configuration
as well as icing based models
um the as a modern
formulation of um
the problem so we have the iso model
which is the classical physics model
corresponding to configurations of
physical eyes and spins
the um this physical model mapped to
many combinatorial optimization problems
with combinatory optimization
of very popular field of optimization
research
within that scope we also involve
nuclear core loading pattern
optimization problems which is our
specific application here
um and within the
the realm of isa models you can find a
feasible mapping
between eisen models to a very well
known binary model in the quantum manila
um space such as popular hardware
missing the d-wave
and fujitsu and this model is known as
the quadratic unconstrained binary
optimization model
um there are a number of powerful kubo
solvers that do exist such as
d-wave and um
within the timeline
of today this is an essential
independent of near-term intermediate
scale quantum computers
some of the icing based optimization
algorithms we considered
included optimized simulated annealing
for spin glasses
the hamza de freitas selby algorithm
and a quantum annealing solution on
d-wave
other algorithms that were considered
included simulated quantum annealing and
spin vector
monte carlo which include ways for the
solution to tunnel through energy
barriers however the lack of high
quality open source
implementations limited our ability to
explore these algorithms
open source solutions are needed to
accelerate
development and testing of potential
solutions to a problem
as well as the ability to validate code
and make sure that the algorithms are
working properly
ideally this would happen in a scalable
language
for some of these high computational
cost problems such as the one that we're
considering
as you can see here we have the industry
collaboration between
uh quantipole llc which is a quantum
machine learning
company and d-wave which is the quantum
hardware company
and one of the key lessons we learned in
this solvency problem was that
we were unable to always constrain
the loading patterns to a 30 30 split of
high and low enrichment assemblies
even though this was a constraint in our
design uh this would require the use of
a fully connected graph however
current side of the debate this is not
possible however we found
that draining our icing model of 30 40
splits
in the assembly type was some somewhat
successful
in uh applying these 33 splitting
constraints
in addition for future studies um other
parameter
uh figures of merit especially
reactivity control
should be considered in the config
configuration
optimization
uh so we have here one of the our
results from chronic connect algorithm
uh and it combines features of both
checkerboard style
and you know loading patterns low
neutron leakage on the
periphery
at the current date we're exploring
solutions
to some of the other algorithms that we
mentioned and hope to have
results on that soon
and for our list of collaborators um
we've had work with a
extensive group of people such as brian
anderson
erica grant travis humble
frank mueller and scott palmtag
for more information on the details of
the cubo and the algorithms that were
considered
we'll be uploading this talk with an
appendix
including details of these algorithms
and the
cubo that was used thank you so much